[Music]
Um I'm Philip. Uh let's talk a bit about
benchmarking. Benchmarketing. Who has
heard the term benchmarking before?
Not not many. Okay. Um so benchmarking
is that what you get in most of the
benchmarks out there. Um even though
nobody calls their own benchmarks like
that. So let's take a quick look. Um who
is using vector search today? I assume
many. Who likes the performance of their
vector search?
Okay. Um who has looked at various
performance benchmarks around uh vector
search? Okay. Quite a few. How did you
like those benchmarks?
Very hard.
Yes. um that is um I have this X is
faster than Y. The problem is that you
can have pretty much any product in X or
any product in Y. I think at this point
we have benchmarks for every single
vendor being both faster and slower than
all of their competitors. Um which is a
bit of a funny sign for benchmarks. Like
why is that? Like are benchmarks just
bad? Is everybody lying? Like how does
it happen uh that benchmarks are so
different? Um don't be shy. Come up
here. We have some more chairs up here.
Um,
also don't trust the glossy charts. Like
the better looking the benchmarks are
sometimes, uh, the worse the the
underlying material is. Um, so let's
dive into it like what to do and what
not to do with benchmarks. Um, come up
here. We have two more chairs up here.
Um, the first thing and that's one of
the biggest ones is finding the right
use case. Um and the right use case of
course depends on for your system. Um
this is one of my favorite benchmarking
comic. It's under similar conditions. We
are comparing two systems and one is
doing much better than the other system.
And that is pretty much exactly what
many system or many companies are doing
with their own vendor benchmarks.
defined
a scenario that they like and probably
their competitor competitors don't like
so much and then run the benchmark and
then afterwards they will say how much
better they are. This is like a very
common pattern for benchmarks or to take
it in a slightly different directions um
a different direction. If you try to
build a benchmarking data set and maybe
you have seen that with your own uh
marketing team is like you run various
scenarios and then you see like this is
no good, this is no good, this is
definitely no good but here you have
struck gold. Um because here um them is
down here and us is up here. So we will
take this one um and then we'll
generalize and generalize and generalize
and say like for everything we're 40%
faster than the competition and you
forget about all the others. Um that is
one of the very common things that you
do with benchmarks. Um and I
I would just call out a couple of things
especially for vector search. Um one of
the things depending on the underlying
data structure that you have and like
this how the system is built um most of
the benchmarks because it's much easier
and also more reproducible um will be
read only oftent times within optimized
format. The problem is most of our
workloads are not read only but pretty
much all the benchmarks that you see out
there are for readonly data sets um
because it's much easier to compare
versus if you have a specific data set
um and then you would need to find the
right read write ratio and like there's
so many parameters that you can do um
that most people just don't and then you
have a benchmark that is not really
representative of what you're trying to
do. Um another thing is um one very
counterintuitive thing about vector
search is that at least for HNSW
filtering makes things slower. So if you
come from a regular data store uh and
you normally you have a restrictive
filter and you reduce the data set let's
say like only 20% of the things make it
through the the filter and you then try
to rank those it will be faster.
The way vector search works or at least
for approximate nearest neighbor search
is that that will actually make it
slower because you need to look at a lot
more candidates and then find actually
what remains after the filter and there
are various optimizations to do that. Um
but that's another trick that you can do
depending if you how good or how bad you
are with filters that you just tune the
right scenario to find your sweet sweet
spot. um or that you have just built in
some optimizations and then you're
making sure that you have a scenario
that hits exactly these optimizations
that your competition doesn't have. Um
another thing that I see quite
frequently especially as people uh
update their benchmarks they normally
always update their own software but
they don't update their competitors. Um
we see that in various benchmarks um
where we are also present as a company
that our version is probably 18 months
old and the competitor has something
that came out in the last one or two
months um and then obviously they will
do quite a bit better there um
so yeah you only update your own version
and the other ones I can understand you
don't want to keep up with the changes
of all your competitors uh you won't
want to figure out like what changed and
how are things uh configured the right
way in a newer version and you're mostly
focused on the interesting things that
you're doing yourself.
It is also convenient for your own
performance. Um
there's also like a lot of implicit
biases. It's like you you know how your
system is built and what it is built for
and how it works well. And then you
might often pick scenarios uh that work
well for those uh for that use case. and
then it might not even be intentional
but then you might pick something that
is just not a very good fit um for uh
your competitors. The same goes for
defaults. It's like how you split up
chart, how you allocate memory, how what
instance size or instance configuration
you pick. Um you might not even mean it
in a bad way or you haven't even
benchmarked the competitor against it on
that specific machine. Uh but you might
just pick something that you know that
works well for you and then conveniently
it's not so great for your competitors.
Um it could be like the shard size, the
total data size, what fits into memory,
how you compress something, uh the
overall memory settings, the the general
data access patterns. There are a ton of
different ways how you could tweak that
uh one way or another. Um and then there
is
obviously cheating. Uh my my favorite
example for that is um if you got the
the forkswagen uh a while ago like they
they had some creative ways uh to look
good in the benchmarks for like how how
much exhaust uh they were producing. Um
I think there was even a a fun project
uh that was uh like a forkswagen plugin
for UCI server that would just always
make your tests pass. Um which is kind
of like the same thing here. And
cheating can be many things for vector
search specifically um approx especially
when you do approximate nearest neighbor
search um where it's depending on how
you pick the parameters and like how how
widely you search um the the quality of
the results will be different or
potentially be different. So precision
recall is normally what we do for
information retrieval. And if you have
different parameters or different
implementations and you don't include
those in the benchmark, um you're
comparing totally different things. And
then it's not totally uncommon to see
it. Uh that precision and benchmarked
are I'm not sure if intentionally or
unintentionally skipped um for for
performance. um but that you then see
widely different numbers but the results
are actually totally different or the
quality is totally different. It's like
obviously you can produce crap results
very quickly um but that is probably not
the point of what you do in your
benchmarks. We actually had some of
those ourselves if people who who are
less experienced in vector search
benchmarks, they forgot about that
quality attribute because for other
types of searches, for example, if you
have a a boolean filter where something
passes and something doesn't pass, this
doesn't exist. Um that they almost
publish something without looking at
precision and recall. And it did make
quite a bit of a difference um even in
our own benchmarks. Um I sometimes see
creative um statistics. Um so one thing
that I have recently seen that was very
funny is like there were like I think 20
data points or so 20 different things
measured and in 18 or 19 two systems
were quite similar and then one system
basically introduced some optimization
for one of the use cases and made it
like 10 times faster than the
competitor. Um and then they found a way
to kind of like even out the statistics
across all of them. And then they said
like overall we're that faster. But they
found this one weird edge case. I think
it was like instead of descending
sorting it was ascending sorting or
something like that um on one specific
data type. And that one was much faster.
And then they even it out enough that it
looked like overall the systems were
wildly different. But it was basically
like one specific query on one of the
many things uh you looked at and then
you have like the headline because
that's mostly what you're going for in
the benchmarks, right? you want to have
this benchmark five times faster than X.
Um, again coming back to the glossy
charts, those are the things that you
you do. Um, and it's kind of like the
the money shot in in benchmarking. Um,
and of course then there are the
problems when data doesn't reproduce.
You don't publish all the pieces that
anybody can actually run this to try it
out. Um, those don't make it easy
either. Um, so how do we make benchmarks
better or more meaningful? um they
should definitely be automated and
reproducible. Um so what we internally
do for example we have a very wide set
of we call them the nightly benchmarks.
That's why up here it says nightly. Um I
just pulled this one out because it was
nice. We we optimized one specific thing
I think like I don't know 100x or 10x or
whatever the ratio was. Uh but we we
optimized this which was nice. But the
important thing here is we run this
benchmark every night and then we put
all the the changes that we had during
the day together to see if the
performance ch performance changes. Why
are we doing that? To avoid the slow
boiling frog problem. Who knows the slow
boiling frog?
It's a very French uh thing. It's like
you know you throw the frog into the
boiling water and the frog will jump out
again. Um you put the frog into the cold
water and slowly heat it up and the frog
will stay in the water. And the same
thing kind of like applies to
benchmarks. If you make a change today
and it makes something 1% slower, you're
probably not going to see it. And next
week you make another change where it
gets 2% slower. And over time your
performance just decreases a lot. Um so
you're the the frog sitting in the
warming up water and being boiled. So
you want to avoid that with your own
system that you don't want to boil your
own performance. Um so you want to have
nightly benchmarks where you see how
things are changing and evolving over
time. Um, second,
this is a bit of an unfortunate thing,
but you will need to do your own
benchmarks. Um, don't trust anybody's
benchmarks and they probably nobody has
done exactly the scenario that you want
to have. It's like you need to know this
is my data size and this is my data
structure and this is the read write
ratio and this is how exactly my queries
look like and this is the latency that I
am willing to accept and this is the
type of hardware that I have. There are
so many ways that make the existing
benchmarks probably not 100% meaningful
for you that if you want to really be
sure, there is no way around doing that
yourself. Otherwise, you will buy
somebody's uh glossy benchmarks and you
will have to trust them and hope for the
best that it actually behaves the same
way. Um
it's unfortunate because it always means
work. Um and you need to put in that
work, but there's no easy way around
that. Um we have like a tool we call
rally. It's basically you create a
so-called track and then you run the
track where you say like this is the
data, this is the query and then you can
optimize that and then you can tune like
the settings or the hardware or whatever
else. It's only against us and ourselves
and this is how we would do nightly
benchmarks with ourselves. uh but that
is how you can then benchmark and figure
out for my hardware what can I actually
get out in terms of performance and then
you will need to take whatever other
tools you want to evaluate and do
something similar to see like for
exactly your workload um how does that
compare
um one final thing and that is also what
I need to keep repeating internally for
ourselves if you find a flaw in a
benchmark it's easy to call the entire
benchmark crap and then ignore
everything that comes out of it what is
much smarter is if if you look at it and
still figure out can I learn something
from that even if it's like somebody pro
produces a a bad benchmark against a
competitor it can tell you like where
they think their sweet spot is or what
is the scenario that they pick for
themselves or what they try to highlight
because even then you can learn like
what are the potential strength of a
system uh where do they shine uh what
works well and what doesn't work well so
all of that makes it easier to find
something useful if you want to look But
it's of course much easier to say like
all of this is crap and we'll ignore it
and we'll call it BS and then you move
on. Um I hope this was useful. Um I'm
afraid you will have to do your own
benchmarks to get proper results. Um
otherwise you will have to uh believe
the benchmarking. Um let me take a quick
picture with you so I can prove to my
colleagues that I've been working today.
Um can you all wave and say
benchmarking?
Thanks a lot. Um, enjoy the heat and
I'll hand over to the next speaker.